[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
please be seated
Provost cotesworth executive vice
president Madigan faculty colleagues
alumni doctoral candidates and their
families and friends good afternoon and
welcome to convocation for PhD
candidates in the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences please do not pinch
yourselves I really am up here
addressing you which means that this is
not a dream that you are truly
effectively and finally done with your
dissertation and with your degree and
may I say what a great Mother's Day gift
you have arranged I thank all of you for
coming to celebrate the many
accomplishments of our PhD candidates we
honor today a magnificent group that on
commencement this coming Wednesday will
join the ranks of our close to 40,000
alumni and who will embark on
professional and academic careers around
the world in the great tradition of
Columbia University equally important we
also honor in this ceremony the families
and friends of our candidates and today
especially the mothers among them who
haven't dueled with them the grueling
marathon of the PhD thank you for being
so supportive and above all so very
patient I would ask that all doctoral
candidates rise and applaud those
friends and family members who have
helped them to be here today
[Applause]
this the student remarks to the
graduating class will be offered by
Ileana geofflove
mr. fluff is a graduate of the
department of genetics and development
and for her PhD dissertation she studied
cell division in the laboratory of
Professor Julie kanmon she hopes to
pursue an academic career to inspire
future scientists mr. Roffe love Thank
You Dean Alonzo dear Provost cotesworth
executive vice president Magadan Madigan
faculty and staff dear families friends
and PhD class of 2018 congratulations
before I started graduate school a wise
mentor gave me a gift but thanks to its
humorous lessons has helped me in times
of crisis that gift was a book titled
surviving your stupid stupid decision to
go to grad school
before I start I want to point out that
my experience is as a scientist so while
my individual struggles vary from yours
hopefully you can relate to the
suffering that I believe is universal to
a PhD journey now I would like to tell
you about how I survived my stupid
stupid decision and what I have learned
along the way I've grown not only in my
expertise on cytokinesis but on how to
be a better person I learned not just to
question everything which I was already
adept at due to a rebellious phase
during my teenage years sorry mom and
dad but how to question and think
critically you cannot trust everything
in papers even if they are published in
nature cell or science and you cannot
disregard them just because they are
published and plus one or the
international journal of fuzzy systems
it seems like common sense but it can be
surprisingly difficult to ask the right
questions in the heat of the moment
where the proper controls used do the
images actually show what the author's
say they do what experiments what I have
done were there weapons of mass
destruction critical thinking is a skill
that seems to be in decline in America
and let me be so bold as to say around
the world extreme views from both ends
of the spectrum are becoming more common
fake news manipulated data propaganda
will we let ourselves get swept up in
the hype or as I sincerely hope will our
experience here give us the foresight to
remain objective and look for the truth
planning experiments taught me how to
manage my time more efficiently waiting
in between time points makes it easy to
procrastinate but the cost can be the
quality of our work having to make up
for lost time by working later still the
cost is losing the interactions we could
be having with their colleagues or even
with our model organisms
unlike other science PhD students most
who come a year or two out of undergrad
I arrived with another mouth to feed my
husband's by the time I graduated there
were four mouths to feed my husbands and
to children's worth working
thank you working with live organisms
meant I could not realistically
entertain more than a one-month
maternity leave much less three months I
also could no longer stay in the lab
until all hours of the night not if I
wanted to change a diaper or two or rub
an aching tummy not to mention I could
not afford to pay for so many hours of
babysitting on my stipend so do i
sacrifice my science or bonding with my
children a little bit of both
I made each moment either in lab or at
home count the Y's book that I mentioned
earlier jokes than in grad school it's
important to keep accurate time so that
you have something to disregard this was
no longer a luxury I could afford
because a wasted minute at work could
mean missing a milestone a first burp a
first giggle a first new scientific
discovery or cure a scientist mother can
dream right it hurt to hear my children
initially direct their mommas to the
babysitter we are all smart here but at
a certain point being smart is not
enough you have to put in the effort and
the hours let us be mindful of our time
we cannot get it back but of all the
skills I've learned the most important
has been how to deal with failure some
people go through their whole lives
being sore losers blaming everyone and
everything else for their problems some
people go to the other extreme and blame
themselves for things outside their
control working through my PhD I learned
how to tell them when something was not
how to tell when something was not my
fault how to take responsibility when it
was and to accept the data as it was
however much I really really did not
need another unpublishable negative
result self-reflection and mental health
are not to be taken lightly I suffered
from imposter syndrome
I used the past-tense loosely like me so
many of my fellow graduate student
scientists and others faced waves of
depression more lows than highs what got
me through was looking for the kernels
worthy of praise my two failed projects
did not take away from the lab
techniques I gained
they do not take away my knowledge from
the research articles I read there will
always be experiments that fail grants
or papers that get rejected perfect data
that for whatever incomprehensible
reason cannot be replicated sometimes
you're just unlucky and a pipe bursts
and floods your lab show of hands who
here has had their lab flood at least
once a document that crashes before we
had time to hit save show hands those
pitfalls have come and gone but we're
still here to tell the tale because we
chose to keep going I know I will
continue to face failures in my future
we all will do not let them stop us a
relative once told me that at the end of
the day you hope to go to sleep with
three things good health a clear
conscience and your love she forgot to
say your Columbia diploma I am sure we
will use the tools we gained here to get
ahead in our careers but let us also use
them to make our world better I hope we
will share the product of our efforts
with the world in a positive way in the
spirit of Columbia's mission let us
remember to take care of ourselves not
just their physical health but our
mental as well let us remember to be
kind to others even if they do not
always deserve it and let us remember to
keep building our relationships with our
family friends and others because love
does not just happen as the movies would
like us to believe like everything in
life it takes work so thank you and
congratulations again to the class of
2018 may all of my and our stupid stupid
decisions in the future be as rewarding
as this one thank you
Thank You mr. applause today's keynote
address will be offered by professor
Francis Negron montaner who is a
professor of English and comparative
literature at Columbia and an
award-winning filmmaker writer and
scholar she earned her MA in visual
anthropology and Fine Arts from Temple
University and her PhD in comparative
literature from Rutgers University
professor Negron montaner is a founding
board member and former chair the
National Association of Latino
independent producers founder of
Columbia's Latino arts and activist
activist archive and former director of
Columbia Center for the Study of
ethnicity and race
professor Negron Montana good afternoon
- Dean Alonzo Provost cotesworth
executive vice president Madigan
colleagues and most important to the
doctoral candidates your families your
friends it is an honor and a pleasure to
have been asked to address you on this
important occasion today in fact it is
such an honor that part of me wonder why
Dina long so would ask me does he know
what has been on my mind lately
maybe it's because I'm out-of-the-box
scholar whose work takes multiple forms
you know outside of the Academy an
increasingly common modality not a few
students are particularly curious about
how one gets to be almost too cool for
school or is it because I come from a
family where everyone has a PhD
there's therefore I should be an expert
on the subject and perhaps I am but in
our expected way for most people a
member of any minoritized group women
people of color LGBTQ speaking at an Ivy
League PhD commencement is a success
story but not for me not exactly
I went to grad school in the 1990s and
collected three mas before finally
breaking down and applying to a ph.d
program in comparative literature at
Rutgers University you can accurately
say that I went kicking and screaming to
my PhD today many parents would
discourage their children to pursue a
doctoral degree but to my parents both
born in the 1940s in Puerto Rico at a
time of rapid industrialization
obtaining a PhD represented the greatest
possible investment towards a satisfying
job and long-term personal security and
for their generation
it was while not always easy with their
PhDs in English and history in hand
my parents were eventually able to gain
gain steady income and permanent
employment and provide my younger sister
and I with a fairly carefree childhood
yet for my generation the road started
getting rockier faced with the prospect
of limited and limiting employment a
good number of my friends and I took
advantage of minority recruitment
efforts in the United States and left
the island consciously or not we saw
school as a way to delay or perhaps
altogether avoid getting a job and
leading a life we already knew we didn't
want I often tell myself that I relented
on the PhD path to please my mother and
it is true the minute after I
successfully defended my dissertation I
call my mother to give her the good news
my mother started to cry
so did I not because I felt that I had
accomplished a great thing in gaining a
degree but because when I was a child my
mother would often tell me that one only
cries for important things things that
were permanent and could not be changed
like death when I heard her cry from so
many miles away I knew that at least
in her eyes I had accomplished something
significant I had not only earned a
distinction that few people had I was
now and forever an adult someone who
could take care of herself but the
reality also was that many of us in my
generation were lost terrified at
following our own desires and had no
idea what else we could do so we signed
up to become PhDs which its rigor order
and hierarchy graduate school was the
pacifist alternative to joining the
military
this decision however remain difficult
at one level
although I had been trained since
childhood for a life of the mind it was
the family business I saw it as not that
different from selling rugs predictable
and on fulfilling so i infinitely
sabotage my pursuit in part by making
choices that went against my own
professional interest I refuse to take
specialized tests used for admission in
the best universities and although I had
a full scholarship paid by the Ford
Foundation I did not attend the
so-called best schools that indeed these
were considered by choices was confirmed
when a Columbia colleagues once joked
about my academic origins by saying you
went to Rutgers wow you speak good
English true story
I sometimes wonder if I made the right
decision
certainly I enjoy my studies and judging
by my colleagues joke things seem to
have turned out alright for me but my
PhD also brought me to live far away
from my country and my family it made me
a stranger among the stones to recall
Cuban poet Lewis castles famous lines in
a certain way you can say that in my
case getting a PhD was somewhat of a
catastrophe but in retrospect that
outcome is not as best at it as it
sounds bear with me well in today's
usage catastrophe refers to devastating
disasters the term comes from the Greek
words cut
down or against and strophe I turn it
means then to overturn in the field of
narrative studies catastrophe is often
defined as the event that begins the
resolution of a plot as for the recap LT
has written nerve reference to Greek
tragedy catastrophe represents the
moment when the ethical dilemma of the
hero or heroine is made visible a cue of
collective reflection that is
catastrophe is the moment when a given
situation can still have more than one
resolution depending on how we act this
means that we live in a world that seems
increasingly ruled by both natural and
unnatural disasters lava wildfires
racism sexism deportation and even grad
graduate school according to surveys I
read these need not turn into disasters
in fact well handle catastrophes may
avoid disasters in the future at that
point I stopped being a person who asked
whether she made the right or wrong
decision in getting a PhD to become a
full-time student of catastrophe
significantly much of what I learned
came from and return me to Puerto Rico
with a new question that I would like to
pass on to you if the I of a massive
category 5 hurricane devastates your
home what's in your hands if you live in
a poor territory of the wealthiest
nation on earth but the federal
government refuses to provide assistance
what's in your hands if the local
government hides supplies and only
distributes them to their party
supporters letting the rest to rot
what's in your hands even experienced
companies are giving multi-million
contracts to bring back electricity but
months later you are still in the dark
what's in your hands after the September
20 storm most people thought they had
nothing
the hurricane completely destroyed the
entire power grid more than 400,000
homes and caused the death of hundreds
if not thousands of people but while the
loss was great and there
our ship nearly unbearable the majority
of residents responded by giving each
other a hand they rebuilt bridges
fixed light poles planted organic seeds
and set up communal kitchens to to feed
communities which is not to say it's all
in our hands or in our head or heart or
positive thinking like the self-help
industry suggests but even when you feel
that as a newly-minted you have little a
PhD you have little or no control that's
just not the case know that in many ways
you have the most in your hands to shape
a different world than any prior
generation information technology and
more importantly a desire to transform
and connect and also know that obstacles
that seem overwhelming to one person are
more efficiently met when stretching our
hands out to others as a West Indian
proverb puts it many hands make short
work so may find that this message does
not entirely apply to students of the
Ivy League particularly not today
because thankfully you have so much in
your hands your hands are full full of
offers possibilities and very soon a
Columbia diploma yet I think it applies
to all of us for if you could indeed
hold everything in your hands you might
sink in a whale of loneliness the value
of education is not that it gives us
access to knowledge which in the
Internet era is much more accessible
than ever in human history or security
which in a disastrous world is becoming
somewhat relative the biggest value of
an education is that it makes us aware
of our relationship and responsibility
to others for where I stand here in the
classrooms and hallways of Columbia
University I see the beautiful promise
of all your catastrophes a word I hope
that you're no longer afraid after today
not only for you but also for all of us
I leave you then with advice or even a
story
as befits a PhD talking to other PhDs
with a question what in your hands thank
you
Thank You professor degrom Antonelli
I now have the pleasure of introducing
miss Lisa Kao a PhD student in the
Department of Biological Sciences and
the president of the Graduate Student
Advisory Council who will present the
faculty mentoring Awards miss kau today
I have the distinct privilege of
representing all GSEs students and
recognizing two outstanding professors
the Graduate Student Advisory Council
confers the faculty mentoring award to
honor excellence in mentoring PhD
students these faculty members have
demonstrated an exceptional commitment
to supporting their students and guiding
them along a path of educational and
professional development selections for
the faculty mentoring award were made by
graduate student representatives from
GSA s and other columbia schools from a
set of nomination letters spanning all
disciplines
today we honor professor Tanya Lee
Putnam and professor Pamela Smith
professor Putnam the selection committee
was very impressed by the nomination
letters received on your behalf
a few relevant passages from your
nomination letters I accept it below one
student wrote professor Putnam has been
instrumental in my overcoming many
hurdles she has worked tirelessly as an
advisor to improve my thinking and
facilitate networking with the faculty
here and abroad
she has gone above and beyond the call
of duty for me and other students and
thus is deserving of this distinction
and more another student wrote as a
mentor who inspires and challenges her
students through a dedication to their
personal and professional development
Tania simply simply embodies the best of
what every graduate student could long
for in an academic advisor and faculty
mentor another student wrote she's an
incredible scholar advisor and mentor
and is the sort of role model that every
graduate student should have on behalf
of all graduate students at Columbia
University we thank you for your
outstanding mentorship effective
mentoring is not only the key to a
successful graduate program but also
establishes a legacy of quality
mentoring practices for your students we
are honored to recognize your
achievements in the signature element of
graduate education
[Applause]
the selection committee was also very
impressed by the nomination that is
received on professor Smith's behalf a
few relevant passengers from her
nomination letters are accepted below
professor Pamela Smith is the most
dedicated mentor of PhD students I have
met she goes above and beyond in all
respects in terms of time level of
engagement enthusiasm and other things
she is deeply she's a deeply inspiring
scholar and teacher and I hope that this
award will be given to her to recognize
all that she offers and for which we are
so grateful another student wrote
professor Smith has been incredibly
supportive and always finds the time to
meet read comment advice write letters
of recommendation and on top of that to
organize monthly group meetings that she
herself participates in what started as
an oral reading group now has evolved
into an oral plus reading press research
plus writing group her dedication to
educating us is unrivaled she stimulates
interdisciplinary research and
facilitates those connections she sees
the potential and everyone and aims to
bring it out she pushes us to work hard
and think big while staying focused and
grounded she deserves this another
student wrote professor Smith is among
the greatest mentors I have met during
my graduate career at Columbia she's
exceptionally generous with her
knowledge time network and resources her
investment as a committee member goes
above and beyond
she has uniquely created an environment
in which students can share work ideas
under her direction which is the only
truly productive and protected discourse
in which I have been consistently
engaged on behalf of all graduate
students at Columbia we thank you for
your outstanding mentorship effective
mentoring is not only the key to a
successful graduate program but also
establishes a legacy of quality
mentoring practices for your students we
are honored to recognize your
means in the signature element of
graduate education professor Smith is
unable to attend today's ceremony
Sophia Gans a PhD candidate in art
history and archaeology and a student of
Professor Smith is here to accept the
board the award on her behalf
[Applause]
thank you mrs. Cole and congratulations
to professor Putnam and Smith we will
now recognize three PhD students with a
Presidential Award for outstanding
teaching these students were selected
from a large pool of nominations by a
committee that included both faculty and
graduate students Provost cotesworth
would you please come forward
the three students selected to receive
this year's Presidential Award for
outstanding teaching are Nicole Marie
vaco from the Department of English and
comparative literature G Healy from the
department of biostatistics and Mariana
Beatrice Noah from the graduate program
in classical studies first Nicole Marie
gave a co
mr. washio you're an engaged and
passionate teacher who is deeply
invested in feminist pedagogy and
committed to excellence both inside and
outside the classroom students praised
the effort and time you put into
planning your classes and mentoring your
students your openness to new strategies
for teaching your skill in communicating
complex ideas with clarity and grace and
your ability to work with students from
diverse backgrounds and with
dramatically different levels of
preparedness make you stand out among
your peers in your time at Columbia you
have taught a remarkable range of
courses in the core English and
comparative literature gender and
sexuality studies human rights and more
and beyond Columbia you worked hard to
provide curricula for the incarcerated
and lower-income students no matter the
audience you consistently foster a
classroom culture in which students are
active visible and responsible
participants you achieve a wonderful
balance between presenting hard
questions and pushing the rigor of your
students analyses you create a community
where students have room to voice and
practice or interpretations and to set
and achieve their goals for the course
you have a clear vision of the work the
humanities can do in the promotion of
social justice and it shines through in
every class you teach it is with
gratitude admiration and pride that we
recognize your outstanding contributions
and accomplishments in the classroom and
beyond with a 2018 Presidential Award
for outstanding teaching by a graduate
students
Jeannie
for the last 4 years
you have served as an invaluable asset
and inspiration to students at the
mailman School of Public Health
you have selflessly given your time and
encouragement to students of all
abilities and backgrounds and your
students are uniformly appreciative of
your enthusiasm and passion for helping
them gain confidence many continue to
seek your guidance long after they have
completed one of your courses
some even aspiring to become
biostatisticians thanks in part to your
mentorship you have a natural gift for
teaching complex statistical techniques
in enjoyable and accessible ways as well
as emphasizing how crucial these
techniques are to understanding
important issues in public health your
students describe you as a remarkable
teacher because you emphasized the
importance of learning the basics using
explanations you term impossible not to
understand your students especially
appreciate your upbeat personality and
your sense of humor and your widely
recognized for your teaching excellence
by your peers and faculty alike it is
with gratitude admiration and pride that
we recognize your outstanding
contributions and accomplishments in the
classroom and beyond with the 2018
Presidential Award for outstanding
teaching by a graduate student
[Applause]
Maryana Beatriz
Noah over the past two years you're
teaching in both philosophy and classics
has earned you the highest praise from
your students peers and the faculty you
inspire your student your students who
think deeply and creatively and you
empower them to find their own voices as
the next generation of leaders you have
shown unmatched initiative in drawing a
greater and more diverse number of
students into conversations about
philosophy art justice agency and beauty
your students speak with enthusiasm
about you and the impact you have had on
their educational paths they cite the
very high standards to which you hold
yourself and describe you as a role
model they admire your passion for the
material and your dedication to teaching
and they praised how Plato's pleasures
of reason our lives experience in your
classroom it is with gratitude
admiration and pride that we recognize
your outstanding contributions and
accomplishments in the classroom and
beyond with the 2018 presidential
classroom
I'm sorry Presidential Award for
outstanding teaching by a graduate
student
[Applause]
thank you
congratulation to mr. washio miss Li and
Miss Norway on their achievements before
we proceed to the presentation of the
candidates for the degree we must pause
to celebrate the life and
accomplishments of one who was taken
prematurely from us and whose life both
a Columbia and outside its gates was
exemplary in a number of significant
ways
Davonte wade was killed in a tragic
active violence on November 26 2017
informed by his own background in a
low-income neighborhood plagued by
violence
the vance research examine examine
examined the detrimental effects of race
inequality educational disparity and
incarceration on communities of color
while at Columbia Devon Devon was a
founding member of the student of color
Alliance an organization devoted to
fostering community and inclusion for
all on the representor graduate students
in the university in addition Devon
served as a research fellow for Columbia
Law School and was an advisor to the men
of color Alliance an initiative of the
Columbia College and Columbia
engineering Office of Multicultural
Affairs from 2005 to 2007 teen he was a
representative mentor and spokesperson
for no more victims Inc a not-for-profit
organization in his hometown in Houston
Texas
supports the children of incarcerated
parents davon thought or was a teaching
assistant in the courses sociology race
crime and law in 2017 sociology of crime
in 2016 and sociology of work and gender
in 2014 in his teaching he fully
embodied the quotation of W EB voice
that he used as a signature in his
personal website education must not
simply teach work it must also teach
life although his career was only just
beginning
the van's work and the passion he
brought to it resonated widely as
evidenced by the coverage of his
research and of his demise by a number
of media outlets in a series of
interviews on his life and work for one
such outlet the vans threw out a
personal note that expresses a seamless
way in which he joined the personal and
the communitarian dimensions of his
being being what makes me unique I would
say is I'm divine I think that you know
we all have so many ways which we
intersect and that we are alike and I
think we don't attribute that but for me
and I think that they're a whole lot of
things that we always ins we are kind of
different unique right and I don't think
it's just kind of one thing or other but
I think it's just that I kind of choose
to live my life in a way that is
constantly aware of my identities and
what I bring to a space and what others
bring to the space and being aware of
them and what they can add what I can
and there was so very much that Devon
added to the communities in which he
lived lived and worked to turn the Von's
life into an inspiration for those who
follow the Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences has instituted a price the
Devon the--wait mentorship and service
award that will be awarded each year
henceforth a convocation for PhD
students at which and which will
recognize the student who embodies the
ethos and activism that characterized
him furthermore we wish to acknowledge
the significance of the Vans original
research at the time of his death Devon
had produced a first draft of his
doctoral dissertation on the effect of
parental incarceration on children to
recognize that achievement the
Department of Sociology recommended
unanimously to the Graduate School that
it award posthumously the degree of
Doctor of Philosophy to him present here
to receive
present here to receive the diploma for
the degree our devons mother Susanne
Wade and his brother Stefan wave
[Applause]
more than everyone I just want to say a
few things one to divine dr. Byrne way
my brother I want to let you know I'm
proud of you
and yes we made it we did too
thank you to Columbia for for this
moment and opportunity to receive this
accomplishment for my brother and to not
show that everything that he did was in
vain and and just because he's gone just
just wash it away and I really
appreciate that thanks to all those
friends and colleagues I doctored the
runway who helped to see this through
who helped to see his legacy continue
and continue for more thank you
[Applause]
I guess first of all I want to say that
I'm thank you Colombia because I feel
like this University was like the
cornerstone they laid the process for
his success and I'm I'm sorry I'm so
emotional thank y'all for giving us
opportunity to be here as a family we
thank y'all for y'all love support
prayers and we're here and I want to
first thank God for being here to accept
this very honorable award on behalf of
my son Devon dr. devon tyrone wait thank
y'all and i want to make sure i give a
special thanks to the dean to the dean
all the professors the administration
the whole faculty the students his
friends and all my family for being here
to support us as well you all installed
upon him and helps him and encourage and
inspire him in all his academics and
endeavors and he was a young man well
grounded loved loved helping others he
sacrificed so much and he broke through
so many barriers and I want to thank you
Devon for laying this legacy of
breaking through barriers because we can
all do whatever we choose to do if we
put our mind to it you know he was a
truthful a warrior and he loved to
debate his opinions if anybody know
Devon he's a but he's a sho'nuff debater
and not only that he was somebody who
always reached back to help others
and he'll of happy to youth you know
never forgetting his roots where he come
from and he would even toot on line even
if he was a cross country if anybody
called him and helped annex for his help
I mean you know this is the type of
sacrifices he made because he loved
helping others and he was someone who
chose not to be a product of his
childhood environment but to inspire
other children to be all that they can
be and he became all that he could be
and I mean his life was just beginning
actually his career and he would be
greatly missed
now all we can do is continue to keep
his legacy alive you know standing in
the gap of truth equality and opening
doors of achievement in all areas of
academic in honor of dr. devon Tyrone
Wade and I want to thank you all
[Applause]
we now arrive at the central point of
the ceremony the presentation of the
doctoral candidates we ask you to come
forth as we call your name in
recognition of your individual
accomplishments professor Andy Tucker
will read the names of the PhD
candidates as they approach the podium
from Anthropologie Samantha Fox Denise
to Ruiz Julia fireman Yulia Grinberg
Surratt Kurt
Patrick Mason zushio son chole jessica
jung min Lee Applied Physics Dennis Wong
channel Kim anthropology Stacy low Tamar
Blix teen art history and archaeology
Caitlin Beach Emily cook Lindsay cook
Carrie Cushman Sophia Ganz
Elizabeth call Nick Maggie mustard
Robert fuchi Joseph Shire Dahlberg
[Music]
Matthew teddy
Robert wiesen burger astronomy Maria
Teresa
Alexei Jenna Tov
David handle Alejandro Nunez Sarah
Pearson Jung Jung biological sciences
David Melamed Susan Newcomb neo Kato
Ludmila colvett Rock Joo Jung Yu Cheng
Lin biomedical engineering
Danielle Bogdanov it's Kristin Ernie
[Applause]
Nicholas caramel legis samiksha nyuk
smruti Shura Prakash biomedical
informatics Jonathan Chang
fernanda Caroline de graa polar Polar
brain off
dreshkana couch biostatistics ki young
Park business Bosch East Avenue 'la Ryan
do Jeon chun-yan Carlin ski she card
cheat on Ren nan Lee
Nancy ran Shu Jackson Liu
Ashley Martin biostatistics ji Healy
business
Zoe Molina papooses Alessandra Piazza
Kunal such TiVo cellular molecular and
biomedical studies Jaime ever leasing
Udit crib L Bower Chama Madhu bata
systems biology Eric lied awake
cellular molecular and biomedical
studies Darshini mahadevi a chemical
engineering
Johnny Ren young say leave me well
Francisco REM Ilana mingle Shay Eileen
Bening Natalie Labrador Wei Ming one
chemistry boom a boat is Bonnie Choi
Samuel Sanders Jonathan lo Leslie
hamachi she she Joo Joo Eun yoshu
yunjeong John Liu civil engineering and
engineering mechanics youngji au c whae
ma see you Chu ji Xiu Yin Lynn Classical
Studies
Zachary Hertz communications Maxwell
Foxman
Katelyn Shore computer science
Emilio Kota Weiwei jong-un Kong IPE
gwang-soo pani Sica corn Shiva corn
Brian Smith Chanute sigh function sue
bing Chu Adrienne tang Jacob barley
Stuart Hatfield Jin Yu Shi earth and
environmental engineering Ming Gao Shou
Xuan Wang summit Ozturk Masahiko
Haraguchi earth and environmental
sciences Kyle fresh corn
Olivia Clifton Alexandra bouche
James Gibson Natalie acardo
Celia Eddie Helen Janna chefs key Hannah
Rabinowitz
Norum a CEO Lee Karen measurement you
Chaco she you chun-li East Asian
languages and cultures clay eatin no gag
a nanny ecology evolution and
Environmental Biology Maresa takahashi
Amrit 'some nila Contin Benton Taylor
economics so Yunnan Sakai ando Ashna
Aurora Daniel Rappaport Vikramaditya
data Valentin soma govinda Rochambeau
jean-jacques for neuron Tom Geng Chun
Chun ha miru Kim
seung-wan Kim Andrew kochenko Seung Hoon
na Nathaniel Neely
I'm Gwen 92 Krishnaswamy Lynn ton T on
Donna Thomas twirl
sing hey whoo
Electrical Engineering
Tolga dink Jung Hwan Kim
hon when quo Gotham Ganga sunny you
yaling Emanuel Peters when's early
Johnny Lee Shin when yo you Chang Chang
electrical engineering Qing Qiu English
and comparative literature rachel john
christopher McKean Candice Cunard
Matthew martini Christina Iglesias
Rebecca Hildebrand Nicole Gervasi Oh
lamb you Maria beau Michael West
Environmental Health Sciences Whitney
Cowell PhD epidemiology Jennifer Ferris
epidemiology Emily green Justin Knox
Stephanie Kujawski
Aaron Ryan Kulik Suzu a sight Oh Megan
work bogus genetics and development
Michael Smith Germanic languages
Vincent Kesling history West Stanley
also not
[Music]
George um what John Chen and a Danziger
Halperin Eric Hirsch tall
med bearish pani Carlos Zuniga Nieto
Colleen Jones chen-wong comes Katherine
lost Oh
Luke who's a Luke coos hola hola
industrial engineering Irene lo
operations research one Xuan Cheng Jun
mo yen on pay genetics and development
Elena giraffe loss operations research
be Shou Italian araignee boola
latin-american Liberian cultures
Adrienne Espinosa Stannis Miguel
Ibanez our estando Agnes Accord a bow
[Applause]
Wendy V Muniz Mariana Cecilia Velazquez
mathematics James Cornish Ming hongyeon
Ramey vandevander Brown
[Applause]
Daniel Gulotta ggf Wong Fei cheat young
Sebastian Picard mechanical engineering
John Gyeongju so you on Chong Xin Jin
Jian Kang duck I be on
Ghita one Arafa Middle Eastern South
Asian and African Studies
Ronnie henyk Wendell Marsh Aditi Sri
funds Akatsuki music galen de Grasse and
[Music]
Levitsky Thomas Fogg William Mason
Trevor Reid says are : Monty Oh Kevin
halt
Whitney Slaton
[Music]
music dma Taylor Brook nursing Megan
reading youngmee woo neurobiology and
behavior Kathryn Shakman
pathology and molecular medicine jindo
pathobiology molecular medicine
Changu pharmacology and molecular
signaling daniela Torres Brian Mao
nutritional and metabolic biology Diego
share Bo philosophy
Nathan vice Jorge Morales Robbie koala
physics Andrew Brainard David carrot le
Jeffrey owatta Rhine Carbone
[Applause]
[Music]
Zachary Greene
[Applause]
Laura Havener Matthew Anthony Felix
Clark
[Applause]
Ben margulies Eric Andrade Angelo
Esposito drew Adel Berg jeong-hee Chung
King John Gow rungy Wong ting ting Wong
political science
Brian Blankenship and regalo
Robert marks Goodman
[Applause]
Michael Rubin King why you Gabriella
scat sacrimoni loot Lots
Stephanie Schwartz amber spry
Adam Zelizer Karolina Faro so young
psychology
Kirsten Fraser
[Music]
Rebecca more Claudia Regina Schneider
Mattie for a Katelyn Williamson
[Music]
Judy shoe religion Hassan Azad
Tara rock singer Shauna sippy Slavic
languages arena denisenko Bradley Gorski
[Applause]
Brenden me Bert
[Music]
sociology Nathan Dern byung-kyu Lee
[Applause]
rosemary McGonagall Gonzalez Warren
McKinney Kristen Murphy Joan Robinson
sociomedical Sciences Amy Dow statistics
Christopher Dolan David Hirschberg
Yongkang
[Music]
[Applause]
Louis Buchalter Mattel okay gonzalo Mina
leash achoo susana McCullough
Maria de los angeles race' Juarez
Swapnil sunny statistics Phyllis Juan
jingzhong sustainable development
usually do Goa Francis Annan
ja hyun-joong Teachers College politics
and education Samuel Abrams Teachers
College comparative and international
education Debra Landis
Teachers College speech and language
pathology Dana Moya Sepulveda TC
economics and education Miguel Martinez
TC English education Morra purse
Patrick Scanlon Miriam Alikhani Teachers
College cognitive studies in education
jungchi's Shah TC mathematics education
Chi Cheung Tom
TC science education melody mirth ting
TC English education Jung Joo you
applied behavior analysis nor Eunice
Sian Madeleine Frank applied Behavioral
Analysis Catherine Cameron georgette
Morgan Ashley Greer
[Music]
Carolyn Crosby
[Applause]
Alexandra Lanter
Laura Darcy Kelly Kleinert
[Music]
Emme marilla's
Peter Theatre Amanda cult
[Applause]
thank you for
and now my closing remarks to the
graduating class with a percent we with
the procession of scholars across this
stage today you have been treated to the
seemingly inexhaustible variety of
fields and departments encompassed by
the Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
at Columbia yet regardless of the
discipline in which you will receive
your doctoral degree this coming
Wednesday what you have learned during
your stay here has not been just a way
of asking questions about particular
objects but the discipline of
interrogation itself hence you should be
proud of and faithful to what you have
learned here but the discipline of
asking questions requires that you not
be so proud of and so faithful to that
knowledge that you be unable to critique
the very education that you have
acquired in this institution in order to
be continually open to the new you must
be able to take your distance from the
presumed necessity of what you have
learned here to challenge the very
things that define you as belonging to
your academic origins to entertain at
every turn the possibility of
self-imposed exile from your
disciplinary home it will be at such
moments that you renew the legitimacy of
the degree that you are about to receive
today and the trust that this
institution has deposited in you by
granting it at such moments he will be
worth remembering that you will confer
this degree so you would ask questions
critically doggedly
undone sparingly even if the one not
spared be yourself in fact the kind of
openness to the new that I'm invoking
and the vigilance required for it to
manifest manifest itself continually in
your scholarly life you
learned every single day in the
negotiation of all the experiences with
which life will present you all the
daily instances in which your capacity
to confront change or to become the
agent for change will be challenged not
just but why is by what is new and
unforeseen but even more forcefully and
dangerously by what is customary and
what is expected of you the vexing gift
that your Columbia graduate education
has given you will require you to
continuously entertain in your mind the
most radical thought experiments what if
the world were otherwise than it is what
if you should not be whom you thought
you should be and then to reimagine both
the world and yourself anew it is a gift
that keeps on taking that continually
makes ever larger demands of you
remember that you were methodically
trained to be an agent of new
understanding and that preserving the
authority of received knowledge is
decidedly not the reason why Columbia
will hand you a graduate degree next
Wednesday today surrounded by the
community of your graduate colleagues
faculty mentors and family members and
despite the toil and sacrifices of your
graduate years you begin what in reality
will be your most arduous and solitary
assignment yet keeping your intellectual
life aflame on your own and allowing it
to consume everything even your most
cherished ideas and beliefs this is the
thorny rose the sweet burning without
Circe's that your graduate education at
Columbia has given you as a gift and the
one you will henceforth have to nurture
rigorously and lovingly by yourself
the Argentinian writer Julio Cortazar
once described described what happens
when we were given a watch on our
birthday with words that seemed
uncannily appropriate to this moment
he wrote think of it this way when they
give you a watch for your birthday
they're gifting you with a tiny
flowering he'll a wreath of roses a
dungeon of air they aren't simply
wishing you many more birthdays and we
hope it will last you it's a good brand
you know Swiss 17 jewels they aren't
just giving you this minut stone cutter
that will bind you by the wrist and walk
along with you they're gifting you they
don't know it it's terrible that they
don't know it they're gifting you with a
new fragile and precarious piece of
yourself something that's yours but not
a part of your body that you have to
strap to your body like your belt like a
tiny furious bit of something hanging
onto your wrist they gift you with the
job of having to wind it every day the
obligation to wind it so that it goes on
being a watch they give to you with the
obsession of looking into jewelry shop
windows and paying attention to the
radio announcer to check the exact time
they give you the gift of fear that
someone will steal it from you that it
will fall on the street and break they
give you the gift of the watches brand
and the assurance that it's a brand
better than any other brand they gift
you with the ump impulse to compare your
watch with other watches they aren't
give giving you a watch you are the gift
they're giving you to the watch for its
birthday we at the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences know that you will
take meticulous care of this demanding
and thorny in
electro gift happy birthday to you all
we arrived then at the end of this
magnificent ceremony go forth to be a
representatives and emissaries to the
world and all of us at Columbia will
rejoice in your inevitable achievements
prosper and prevail make us and your
relatives and friends prouder still
today about you brother still about you
than we are today well the candidates
stand so that we may give them a final
round of applause please
you're all invited to a champagne
reception immediately following the
ceremony on Avery Plaza under the tent
I asked friends and families to wait to
exit until after the faculty and
candidates have ascended the steps to
the upper campus once again ladies and
gentlemen we ask that friends and family
wait to exit until after the faculty and
graduates have ascended the steps to
upper campus please join us for a
reception at Avery Plaza
[Music]
[Applause]